when I started playing Magic Mulligan
seemed like a largely uncomplicated
subject if your hand is okay you keep it
if it sucks you don't and for the most
part this analysis reflected the actual
state of the game see for the first
several years I played the game the
official Mulligan rule was the Paris
Mulligan if you don't like your hand of
seven you can draw a new hand of six if
you don't like that hand you can draw a
new hand of five and so on in some
competitive constructed applications you
might have planned out some sort of Mull
policy for yourself but the general idea
especially in limited was uh try not to
mull again because it sucks especially
with regard to Mana screw if your deck
is 40% lands a seven card hand averages
2.8 lands if you Mullan after drawing
too few lands the six card replacement
hand will average 2.4 lands God forbid
you need to go to Five because that hand
will average two lands and will have a
greater probability of having one land
than having three lands
yikes in addition if there's a couple of
pivotal cards in your deck every
Mulligan you take means a turn later
that you'll see one of those cards
meaning that your midgame potential is
compromised as well however this all
changed in 2019 the introduction of the
London Mulligan meant that since you get
to see a full hand of seven cards with
every Mulligan it's no longer the
painful Choice it used to be this is all
the more true in Commander where you get
one for free the filtering value in
being able to pitch a hand and get that
same number of cards again is legitimate
and shouldn't be underestimated taking
that first Mulligan has no cost to you
other than that it requires taking your
first Mulligan so if you aren't using
that Mulligan regularly every few games
at least you're actively giving up on a
resource the game is handing you in
addition going down to six cards or even
to five cards isn't that big a cost for
a lot of techs it's a bit painful and
limited because card effects and power
levels are less diverse so drawing a
different set of lands generic beaters
and non-creature spells often won't feel
worth the cost of losing one of them
however in Commander cards vary wildly
despite my personal wishes for the
format just about every deck runs a
piece of fast Mana that will
dramatically warp its early turns if
drawn and there are a number of other
cards that will similarly have an
outsized impact if drawn in the opening
hand other lowcost ramp spells like
birds of paradise lowcost draw spells
like Mystic rora or skull clamp and high
impact creatures such as professional
face breaker or Academy manufacturer a
six or even five card hand with one of
the deck's best cards will often be a
lot better than your average seven card
hand in addition as I mentioned in my
lands video the existence of a commander
creature means that decks will have a
pre-selected card that's effectively in
hand at all times this means that when
you mull again you know that whatever
hand you draw will have access to that
creature as long as you like your
commander it's literally possible for a
hand to have access to no good cards so
Mulligans are a great tool and
developing your skill in something as
superficially simple as saying yes or no
to a given hand will generate you tons
of advantage through additional free
filtering in the long term in addition
not only are there relevant decisions to
be made during a given game but the
influence of Mulligans on your
decision-making process begins while
you're still building your deck we can
see an indication of this immediately
with the number of lands people choose
to run in decks if everybody had to keep
their first hand every time I suspect
that you'd see way more decks
gravitating toward land counts in the
low 40s the range that maximizes the
odds of a three land hand but nah if we
draw too few lands the cost of drawing a
new hand is relatively low due to the
previously mentioned factors and the
odds of drawing a workable hand within
the first three drawn is pretty high
there are also people who adhere to this
principle much more strongly than just
absent-mindedly tossing 30 lands in all
their decks there's a particular person
in my comments section who Advocates a
land count of around 28 for most lower
curved decks with the logic being that
an aggressive Mulligan policy can be
employed to guarantee a high probability
of drawing into enough lands to function
and let's consider that plan for a
moment a given hand in a deck with 28
lands will have a 36% chance of having
zero or one lands a 33% chance of having
two lands and a 31% chance of having
three or more lands
if we're willing to mulig into six to
see up to three hands of cards this
gives us a 95% chance of seeing a hand
with at least two lands and a 2/3 chance
of seeing a hand with at least three
lands these aren't the worst odds
especially when you consider that there
might be low cost draw lowc cost tutors
lowc cost ramp land cycling and other
tools that can make a two or even one
land hand keepable however this also
calls back to the idea of Mulligans as a
resource getting to see see more hands
of cards has filtering value and
constructing a deck in the 28 land
framework means that that filtering
resource is basically spent exclusively
looking for the right land count now
this can be fine if you really trust
your non-land cards to be valuable and
trust your Mana base to give you the
symbols you need but you're still giving
up a bit of ability to hunt for good
nonland plays as a demonstration of this
we can think of a hand that has two
lands and some desirable non-land cards
decent hand I'd happily keep it but what
if we just made some changes to the deck
and one of these lands got cut for a
ledger Shredder suddenly this hand has a
very high risk of missing at least one
early land drop and we might need a
mulligan for a different hand a hand
that will likely have worse non-land
play the point here is that running
fewer lands will lead to a greater
frequency of needing to reject hands
with desirable non-land play if we're
looking for a hand with two to four
lands running a land count of 30 will
give us that 66% % of the time whereas a
land count of 40 will give us that 76%
of the time 10% might sound like a small
difference but think about it this way
almost a third of the hands that the
hypothetical 30 land deck needs to
Mulligan due to land count are keepable
by the 40 land deck and those hands
might contain some really great cards
this doesn't mean that running more
lands is objectively correct there
definitely are decks where having a
lower chance to top deck a land is
especially desirable but it does
demonstrate some of the trade-offs
involved with running different land
counts and the way that higher land
counts and better Mana bases for that
matter can increase the filtering value
of the Mulligan step let's say you
decide to lean more in the direction of
filtering for non-land carts what's a
good thing to do with this filtering
well a lot of decks will have a
particular thing they're looking to find
for example a piece of ramp is a
frequent want for decks with a specific
curve in mind as is the case with the
goreclaw deck I mentioned in my lands
video in cases like this how many of a
particular type of card a deck should
run often comes down to whether the deck
is okay with drawing multiple copies in
my land's video I showed a formula for
finding the probability of drawing a
card of a type and while 20 cards of a
type does give a comfortable 80% chance
of drawing at least one in any given
hand the flip side is that there's also
a more than 40% chance of drawing two or
more and there is actually a lower
chance of drawing exactly one copy than
there is running a count of 15 or even
10 some decks won't mind multiple copies
of whatever they're looking for but for
a deck looking for a diverse range of
cards or a deck that is tight on space
running 10 to 12 copies and mulliganing
aggressively for them might be a better
plan than running 15 or 20 another
consideration that's especially relevant
for higher Powers is that decks can be
built with the intent to Mulligan in
different ways based on the opposing
decks and the turn order in certain
matchups it might be correct to mle
aggressively for a hand that will make a
bunch of bold plays early in a rush to
gain dominance whereas a different deck
pool in turn order might make a grindier
hand with quality drawn interaction a
much more appealing one to stick with at
this point I think I should mention I've
been presenting Mulligans as a filtering
resource which might imply that each
deck has a set quantity of this resource
that it should spend all of and this is
the easiest way to think of it but it's
not exactly correct willingness to
Mulligan will differ person to person
and deck to deck and how tightly a given
player leverages their Mulligans will
generally depend on three factors one of
these factors is how much they care
about the quantity of cards they start
the game with I mentioned that
constructed EDH decks have more card
variation than limited decks and this
effect scales with power level in cedh a
single power card like doite
extortionist or esper Sentinel might
redeem an otherwise painful Five Card
hand and a high Den it of specific
Stacks pieces means that ditching a hate
card against three commanders that
aren't generally all that affected by it
isn't a large cost at all another factor
that will influence Mulligan willingness
is a player's risk tolerance and this
actually works in both directions a
player who wants to sit down at the
table and have a game where they're
guaranteed to do something might be
willing to keep a slow hand rather than
risking finding a worse one and a
different player could use the same
reasoning to Mulligan aggressively for a
great hand because they don't TR their
top decks on the flip side we can
imagine Daredevils of multiple Stripes
boldly keeping or mulliganing and
believing in their deck to deliver them
greatness ultimately this factor is a
matter of personal preference more than
anything and will mainly come down to
what different people find fun the final
factor in determining Mulligan
willingness is how confident a player
feels in their mulliganing skill less
experienced players and players who
don't know their deck as well will often
be inclined to keep a mediocre but
workable hand that a more experienced
player would happily toss out to hunt
for a better one this is a skill you can
work on and the best way to do this is
to understand the ratios of different
things in your deck and How likely each
is to get drawn either in an opening
hand or in the first several draws of
the game it's useful to know that your
opening hands will contain an average of
2.5 lands and 2.2 cards above three mana
and that they'll have a 70% chance each
to contain at least one piece of ramp
and draw if this feels like a nebulous
process to in practice you can also do
lots of play testing draw opening hands
play out the first few turns rinse and
repeat and actually doing a combination
of these two pre-play analysis and play
testing is the quickest way to build
intuition as to how various deck
building choices will turn into
practical early game results it's easy
to see your library as a mystical Black
Box to deify it as an entity that will
either bless you with wonderful cards or
curse you with all the wrong stuff but
it's not that the way the cards in your
library turn into hands is predictable
in a probabilistic sense and getting a
better feel for that will improve your
ability to play your deck both in the
Mulligan phase and
Beyond